darío they might have to turn from their
back to have to be honest so in part two
of the tutorial I just had a chat in the
break and Aaron was telling me that they
would do a noisy version of the
selection instead of using a random
split of the data for a selection and
I'll start exactly
good
so I'll start this tutorial by showing
you that doing the selection on a random
split of the data and doing a noisy
version of selection with a specific
noise scheme are actually asymptotically
equivalent so so what I hopefully
convinced you in part one of the
tutorial is that maybe carving is the
right way to go which achieves like best
of the two worlds both splitting and Lee
at all but okay so let's look at this
example of carving so again we are back
in our to our example the lasso just
that now I randomly choose a fraction of
the samples to run my lasso on now I can
write this lasso objective as an
objective on the entire data so I
express the Gaussian law in terms of the
entire data I added subtracted this term
basically and what is RORO is basically
the fraction of my data points that I'm
using in selection it's n 1 over N say
I'm using half of my data for selection
then Rho is just half so I can interpret
this quantity so I still have the same
objective
I added subtracted a term which is the
lost Gaussian loss based on the entire
data vector so I can interpret this as a
randomization term basically actually
that's not completely correct I can
interpret the gradient of this thing
with respect to beta as a randomization
term so there is a typo in there and if
we look at so if we look at the gradient
of this term and interpret it as some
randomization
then it's easy for us to see that this
is asymptotically Gaussian with mean
zero and some covariance matrix Sigma
it's just basic asymptotics that you can
try and see that the gradient of this
term happens to be asymptotically a
Gaussian random variable with mean zero
and variance covariance matrix Sigma so
what carving is
I want all of us to get to this page yes
so since this is somewhat far enough
where should we think of the randomness
is coming from it's coming from the
splits from the fact that you have
randomly chosen a split of the data on
which you conducted your selection so
I'm casting it as this optimization
problem so say la so for instance but
you could imagine any objective that you
are trying to minimize and I just say
okay I I ran this lasso on this random
fraction of the data but I do a little
math like I add subtracted term and if I
determine by this how does that choice
of whether it's tiny versus large how
does that affect the variance of the
Gaussian it does affect so this Gaussian
distribution is a function of Rho which
is basically the splitting fraction the
fraction of your data points that you
use for selection and there is a
trade-off between selection and
inference so the more the data you of
course used for selection you are you
know using up more information during
selection and you're left with now the
next question is is this count is this
noise Gaussian because of what we're
computing because we're looking at last
if you were doing so no no it is not it
is pretty general in nature it just
comes from class like look analyzing the
asymptotic distribution you can see it
like in the simple case if I just tell
you that I mean you can check this
yourself so let's look at the simple
example where I was say I have
observations this come IID from some
distribution s my selection criterion is
root and vine bar greater than lambda
this is basically our z statistic in
statistics let the because so we are
inferring about the mean of this
distribution F say if Z statistic
happens to be greater than lambda so
instead of this say I use instead a
random proportion n1 of data to do my
selection so this is my selection
criterion right now what I would say
like if I rewrite the selection
criterion as root n Y n1 n bar plus add
subtract this term basically
then you can see that this term is
asymptotically a Gaussian because you're
just looking at square root n vine bar
minus the difference of mean scale by
square root N and you get the right
scale to randomize you get the scale of
this randomization error which is
asymptotically a Gaussian by just
analyzing the distribution of the
difference of the means so that's where
it intuitively comes from maybe you're
gonna go in this direction but like the
way you wound up the previous tutorial
you said okay rather than trying to
select based on the whole data and
conditioning on the whole data part of
the data yes look at the conditional
distribution of the entire dataset and
in some sense what what that is doing is
saying okay it's some abstract level
you're just taking a different selection
procedure right rather than using the
whole data and running low so you're
running lasso on a random sample the
sort of possible design space of
selection procedures is much larger than
that right there like you know lots of
different things you could do presumably
this when you're choosing this is design
procedure you're you're optimizing for
some for something and I guess my
question is and maybe you'll get there
is like if I don't suppose I'm not
married to lasso I don't really care
about lasso I just want to pick the best
design procedure the best selection
procedure what should I be I'm not so I
am not very concerned about like I'm not
the one who is doing the selection but I
think like to answer your question I'm
I'm exactly not the one who is
optimizing over the selection objective
but I think it's somewhat related to
Cynthia
question of like determining this row
because there is certainly a selection
trade-off between selection and
inference which is determined by this
row parameter so there is a question of
what how do you want to fix the scale of
randomization which depends on basically
this row parameter how big of a
subsample that you want to take so there
is this trade off and when I analyze the
data set I can tell you like the rule of
thumb that I use is that I check the non
randomized selection and I try to be not
too different in my like I don't my
findings don't turn out to be so
different from the non randomized
selection that's what I care about
because I don't want to randomize my
objective to a great extent that I lose
all the signals and I report completely
different findings from what I would
have gotten without the noise so I don't
want to add so much noise that I get a
completely noisy selection no so I no no
no it's not dead it's not data snooping
like I I do use but I don't what I want
to say is that I'm not like using a very
principled and not optimizing some
objective to determine row here which
gets me some optimal trade-off between
selection and inference so there is
certainly room for getting some
principled way of choosing this row I'm
just telling you a rule of thumb that
typically like you know gives me
selections that are not very different
from the non randomized analog but I'm
not like actually working out an
objective function which I'm optimizing
to get like an optimal row that gives me
some sort of a selection inference
trade-off yet question to make sure I
understand so this connection between
like random splitting and
nice addition the variance of the noise
is like a data dependent quantity right
because if the like for example if the
data was entirely on the genius fun no
this is this is not a data dependent it
just depends on the factor row which you
determine like all of the elements my
data set were the same then there with
the random that like the random split
would have no randomization effects
because no matter what half I took I
would have exactly the same data set
right so every X is the same and every Y
is the same oh but you're I guess you'd
it depends on the underlying
distribution of the data of course it
depends on F but but yeah it's it's this
asymptotic variance is determined by row
like that's the parameter that it has
but let me get to that question I think
a slightly later it becomes clearer so
all I want you to tell you is that
Gaussian random ization scheme is
something very natural that comes up
from this carving idea but let's see a
more mathematical formulation of it
which makes it maybe little more clearer
so just one is mention that Yun and
Taylor which actually introduced
randomization schemes in selective
inferential literature dealt with
randomizations that have much heavier
tails like Laplace and logistic and they
did not talk about gaussian random
ization in particular but I personally
run all my examples with Gaussian around
randomization and I find it more
appealing in nature because it's
something that comes up very naturally
from this data carving idea so let's
look at this randomization scheme I
think this one this objective will make
it clearer so so if you run lasso with a
noise objective sorry with a noise up
term which is linear in parameters beta
where Omega is drawn as Gaussian noise
centered at zero with some scale tau
square so this case tau square is
essentially related to the splitting
fraction Rho I can give you the exact
expression how Rho is related to tau
square because that's what we saw that
data carving was
synthetically equivalent to this
objective where Omega was Gaussian with
some Sigma parameter so maybe this is
more palatable to people here you see it
as it's it's termed as objective
perturbation in differential privacy
literature and it's just form of
randomizing your optimization objective
so I'm going to like even if it's not a
lasso it's some loss and some penalty I
can just add a linear term in my
parameter with Gaussian noise getting
back to my last question for
differential privacy you would pick the
variance of the Gaussian noise to be
something that was independent of like
the data distribution whereas like it in
the square is not dependent on the data
distribution I could fix the scale of
tau square however I want depending on
the extent that I want to randomize my
objective degenerate you would get no
randomness at all by randomly splitting
the data but am i interested indigent
like example it shows that the variance
has to depends on in some way on the
data distribution and this equivalence I
don't see how our square is dependent on
like it's a skill that I fix it's a
scale that I choose so if I and that's
just determining the extent to which I'm
willing to randomize my objective to
make it like noisy to what extent so
it's not really something which is
adding noise there's equivalence from
the last slide which maybe I don't
totally understand where it's dependent
on Rho Rho is the splitting fraction
that's again something which I determine
explicitly that's not dependent on the
data generative distribution I decide
whether I use 50% of the data samples
for selection or 80% of the data samples
for selection
that's a believer the point like again
is my distribution for example
like doesn't put probability 1 on like
want like the same XY pairs of my
dataset was just you know and copies of
the same XY pair it doesn't matter what
half of them I take I'm gonna get the
same the same like data set so there's
no randomization at all you're like I
just have a deterministic procedure now
when I take half of the run lasso it's
the noise what you're saying is correct
that the in the data if you try to think
of data splitting as adding noise than
it is it might not give you like on the
data set right and that is fine and now
now we're looking at a procedure that
doesn't where tau is specified in a way
that okay great yeah it's it's just a
scale that I determine and if like if
your data points all happen to be same
and this I mean I feel all the
inferential principle should still be
should still go through as long as I'm
determining to but or row in the
previous example but it might be that
you might get meaningless selection and
meaningless inference depending on like
what how good your data sample happens
to be so when you're adding haha so
maybe that's fine for going on so the
question is if we have like if this is
the sort of randomization schemes that
we look at whereby we can get a more
generalized version of data splitting in
the sense that now we condition on this
randomized selection event on this noisy
version of selection event and try to
provide inference based on it the
question is now more computational well
we saw the lis at all which gave us a
univariate truncated Gaussian pivot and
it was explicit and there was no
asymptotics involved in there it was
just a finite sample guarantee if you
had really Gaussian data now the
question is could we have something like
the polyhedral lemma coming to our
rescue
even here so let's look at the
randomized lasso objective so it's very
similar to the canonical last objective
except that now it has this linear term
in the parameter so the selection by
lasso is equivalent to again a set of
polyhedral constraints except that now
selection is described in terms of both
your response and randomization noise
Omega yes one thing that's going on o is
all of this sort of conditioning on the
matrix a has known and fixed so a and B
would be functions of what you select so
there would be functions of e say e is
the set of active coefficients you
report there are certainly functions of
selection they're determined so whatever
you select is equivalent to the fact
that I select say five coefficients from
LA so that is equivalent to a polyhedral
region a which is a function of those
five coefficients are we can thinking of
axis this when we're doing the
conditioning so in this example yes yes
but I mean to answer your question you
can also do it with X random so it X
doesn't necessarily have to be fixed but
in this example I'm just taking a fixed
design so now if we look at the same
conditional alright we are looking at
the conditional law of our knife
statistic which will sum ETA prime Y
this was the oil s s like a particular
direction say the first coordinate of
the oil s estimate estimator that we
obtained by refitting a linear model to
our data Y and selected subspace X and
then we conditioned on the selection
event which is now a polyhedral region
defined in terms of your response Y and
randomization Omega that's the only
difference that you have a randomization
in the selection as well and your
condition again on the same recent
statistics that don't give you any
information about the parameter of
interest the point is that this law no
longer happens to be a truncated
Gaussian anymore and to see why it's not
so so if he had a fix just imagine that
if we have this polyhedral selection
region at a fixed realization of Omega
say Omega 1 then of course you know you
again like by conditioning on your
nuisance statistics you can see that ETA
prime Y would be restricted between
gamma minus and gamma plus but as you
can see that the selection is actually
marginalizing over these omegas it's not
a fixed realization of Omega but the
selection probability that we are
computing here is randomizing both over
the data as well as the omegas so if I
what you compute it at a different
realization of Omega which is Omega 2
I'll get another rate to which a
different ray from this one - which ETA
prime Y will be restricted - so it's not
a single polyhedral region like it's not
a single ray that my knife statistic is
no longer wrist is restricted - so as a
result
which I cannot express my selection
event in this form that eita prime why
is restricted to a fixed polyhedral
region sorry to a fixed rate gamma - and
gamma plus but these gamma - and gamma
plus are now random quantities which
vary as you vary your realizations of
Omega which is a random quantity so the
polyhedra lemma of Lee basically breaks
down here so what's natural here you
might say is that okay we might run a
sampler from the law of ETA prime by and
Omega truncated to the selection region
so I have a selection region which is
basically a polyhedral region so I can
instead run a sampler because I don't
have an exact pivotal quantity anymore
since the polyhedral emma doesn't apply
does this look very mysterious it's just
that now I have this the Rays that I was
truncating to earlier I cannot get a
single rate rate which ETA prime why is
truncated two rather there there are
multiple rays which vary as I vary the
instances of randomization so instead
what I can do a natural way is sampling
I would sample the law of ETA prime Phi
and Omega jointly restricted to the
selection region that I described to you
but this is something that we have in
this paper but I kind of am more I like
MCMC free inference I'm not so
comfortable with samplers because I
never know when it's really when my
sampler has converged and when is it
giving me credible inference so to
provide MCMC free inference let's look
at this randomized law let's try and
compute let's understand what this
randomized law is and let's see whether
we can avoid a sampler in some base
tractable way to sample from the right
distribution
arno sampling involves so I'll be
talking about so this paper actually
talks about a sampler which is
essentially trying to truncate from this
randomized law truncate it to the
selection region of the polyhedral
region but I'm going to talk about MCMC
free inference and yeah sampling cream
inference previous slide you said okay
it is not like the selection region is
not an interval there's no and okay I
understood that slide now but now you're
saying what to counted all did was to
select from like I didn't understand
what you said they did go back I think
forward forward sorry sorry yeah keep
going so there is no there is no closed
form expression for a pivot anymore so
we don't have a pivotal quantity what is
I'm trying to understand the text in
blue
okay what is sampling from the to
explain that I'm I'm going back here
okay is it the case that you're saying
sample a random Omega and then pretend
that's the real Omega no no so you have
a so you you can precisely sample from
so you have a joint law of data and
randomization so let me try and
so say I mean let's go back to the
simplest example where I have say I was
talking about route and wine bar greater
than lambda so now instead of this
selection I'm looking at this greater
than lambda right so so what is my
selection
what is the selection adjusted law that
I'm looking at actually I would have
written the largest few slides later
maybe that would be better I can just go
and explain to you what what is
basically what is the law that I'm
sampling from after I explain I mean
I'll go there just understand so I'll
give you correct distribution from the
exact distribution but of course you
would in sampling so you would have
error coming from your sampler because
you're sampling but you're sampling from
the exact law so I'll get to that in in
in few slides and I think you'll
understand that better once I show you
what that law is you know you don't want
a sample you want like an analytic
computation of you know yes I'm avoiding
a sampler but like you will see that we
will need some need of approximation and
why does the need of approximation come
into play I'm gonna explain that in a
bit so we have this randomized lasso
objective now coming to inference I
always have to talk about a model and
the target that I'm inferring about it's
the same target that I've been talking
about so far but let me just go over it
quickly just for consistency's sake I'm
not very happy with the saturated model
but for consistency's sake I'm sticking
to the saturated models that little use
this is also used in the Posie paper
where you assume that your data is
generated as Gaussian with a mean mu
that's some Gaussian noise this is the
model that you're using for inference
your selection output can be
described as a function of your response
Y data Y X and randomization Omega the
target that I'm looking at is the same
old target which is your population
least square coefficient the projection
of the true mean mu on to the selected
subspace of X and again because Li at
all does coordinate wise inference we
just say focus on the first coordinate
of this dimensional vector so my target
statistic so I start with the Knife
statistic which we all use for inference
which is the first coordinate of the
least square estimator projected onto
the selected subspace of X naively if
there was no selection this would have
been Gaussian but the question now is
what is the right law of this knife
statistic if we did perform selection
how do we calibrate the law of the
statistic okay so to see it let's
simplify notations again so we have said
data a statistic Z which is a function
of data we have randomization Omega now
what is the unadjusted or the pre
selective joint law of data and
randomization so in this case I just use
some Gaussian noise so this is my
Gaussian law for a randomization and
this is and it was independent of the
data so and this is the Gaussian say Z
is just univariate Gaussian with mean
parameter B that I'm trying to infer
about and variance Sigma square so this
is the pre selective law Gaussian law of
data and randomization that I start out
with now I know that selection
constraints my data and randomization to
lie in some selection region K in the
case of lasso it happens to be a
polyhedral region right let's describe
both in terms of my data as well as
randomization the question is what is
now the adjusted with the selection
adjusted joint law of data and random
so we started out with this pre
selective law the selection adjusted law
is just the same law is proportional to
the same law truncated to a selection
event and the selection event depends on
you is determined by the selection that
you carried out on the randomized
version of your data so this is the
adjusted law that I'm looking at this is
what it's proportional to so if I run a
sampler I'm going to sample Z and W from
this truncated law this this key the
selection region is determined by the
selection based on that particular
realization of Omega that I carried out
but that gives me the selection adjusted
law and I know sample instances of V and
W from the selection adjusted law that
that's what a sampler would do if that
makes it clear ok so now let's look at
this density a little further so what
I'm interested in is inferring about
parameter B so what is the marginal law
of data conditional on the selection
event so the marginal law can be
obtained by just marginalizing over the
randomization part right this is the
joint law I integrate out the W's to get
the marginal selection adjusted law of
data conditioned on selection so once I
integrate over W what I get is this
factor that probability randomization
lands in this selection region
conditional on the data value pingzhi
right this is just obtained by
integrating over omegas so if I looked
at this selection adjusted marginal log
the data I see that this is an expose
this is an exponential family of laws
how does it compare to the pre-selected
Gaussian family of laws so it is again
it has the same sufficient statistic as
the Gaussian law it has the same natural
parameter as the pre-selected Gaussian
law but what is different here is that
the Gaussian
you have a different reference measure
you have a reference measured
is equal to the Gaussian reference
measure times another function of your
data and that other function of your
data is precisely this probability that
randomization lands in this selection
region conditional on data so you have
to you have this conditional probability
of randomization landing in a selection
region so if I want to avoid a sampler
why can't I try and get a hand on this
quantity unfortunately even for a lasso
this probability doesn't have a closed
form expression it's like I have like
the multivariate Gaussian volume of some
region and I don't know a closed form
expression for it so I resort to
approximation so if I get a reasonable
approximation that has some guarantees
and gives me a reasonably good form of
this property why can't I just use it
and avoid using a sampler so that's what
I'm going to describe next so I hope
this like just gives us a sense of what
the randomized law is so if I were to do
a sampler I would go back here and just
sample from this joint density and
discard these samples of randomization
because they don't I don't use them for
inference but instead now I'm saying
okay let's just compute the randomize
law and let's see what is really the
intractable part in this randomize law
can we go around by giving some
tractable quantity for this intractable
component with some reasonable guarantee
so I use an approximation to compute
this probability to be precise now what
is the guarantee on this approximation
so if we have a convex and a compact
selection region then the guarantee on
this approximation is that the
difference between the log of this
approximate property and the log of the
two probability goes to 0 when scaled
over 1 over n so people who are already
aware of large deviations what this
tells you is that the approximate
probability that a compute captures the
true rate of exponential decay of the
exact probability
very what we had is approximation that I
use I haven't told you what
approximation I use but I just tell you
what's the guarantee on the
approximation theorem there's a
statement like for the P hat in our
paper this statement yes yes so it just
tells you how close like are you really
capturing the exponential rate of DT of
the true probability or not and that's
what this tells you that it does it on a
large deviation scale it's a point-wise
convergence there's no like P or
anything in this statement is that like
it's independent of the dimensionality
of the problem or the number of
significant features or anything like
that the asymptotics is in the sense of
fixed P and n going to infinity yes
that's the sense of asymptotics now let
me tell you give you a sense of how we
compute this approximation so to compute
this approximation all you need to know
is the kkt map of the objective that you
were solving as your selection query
so this KKT map is a function of
randomization your data realization Z
and you can see some variables oh so
it's an affine map in Z and O so what
are all our optimization variables to be
precise in the case of mass or
optimization variables are you sub
gradient variables they are your active
signs and inactive sub gradients which
are constrained to lie in a cube so I
can compute the KKT map and the second
component that I need to know to compute
this approximation is the log is the
conjugate of the log MGF of the
randomization that I use so in this case
I use a Gaussian random ization so the
conjugate of the log MGF of gaussian
random ization is pretty simple it's
just this quantity so my approximation
is precisely given by this quantity
which is a convex objective so the first
part you can see comes by evaluating
this conjugate of the log MGF of
Gaussian
at the kkt map and then I have another
function which I can compute explicitly
I won't tell you what that is to
complicate matters so my take away
message is that the approximation that
we compute here is pretty easy to
compute it's just a convex objective
it's constrained to lie in a region that
is also fairly simple so in the case of
last so it's just like sine constraints
so it's typically constrained to lie in
some or thunde
that's not very hard to compute as well
so and I don't use this constrained
optimization rather I replace this
constraint with a barrier function in my
objectives so that it smoothens the
objective and that's much easier for me
to handle I just use a gradient descent
to solve this approximation each time so
you give know a little bit of intuition
about this approximation so what I was
trying to so the reference measure the
intractable component in reference
measure that I was approximating was
this probability that randomization
landed in a convex selection region that
was what I was trying to approximate and
here randomization has mean 0 so what
this approximation basically tells you
that this probability can be log of this
property can be approximated as the
distance of origin which is the mean of
randomization
from its projection onto this convex
selection region so this is the basic
intuition of the approximation now to
just show you the simple example where
we have univariate gaussians which is
say mean B and we have this fresh
holding event where I look at a
randomized version of the thresholding
event so this is so in this case I can
compute the exact reference measure
right it's just a Gaussian tale in the
simple problem I know what the exact
selection probability is so this is the
exact randomization density which I can
afford to compute in the simple example
but not for general selection rules like
lasso and this is my approximation that
I actually use just to give you a
demonstration of how good the
approximation behaves in comparison to
the exact law so this plot plots the
approximate laws which
in green and the true density which are
in which are the dotted blue lines and
these are four different parameter
values and you see that the
approximation actually does a very good
job in mimicking the true or the exact
reference measure so to obtain I mean
it's I'm not going through it again but
you can just construct a pivotal
quantity so once you have this
intractable you have plugged in an
approximation for the intractable
probability that you did not know you
have the you have a hold on the
randomized law and you can construct a
pivotal quantity from it by simply
looking at this observation and to
compute intervals you look at all
parameter values which satisfy this so
confidence intervals construction is
pretty trivial from here but now I want
to move on and talk a bit about point
estimation so how do we obtain a point
estimate that overcomes selection bias
so if I again go back to the randomized
law what I had in that law is I knew
that the randomized loved belong to an
exponential family of distributions if I
look at the log partition of that
exponential family of distribution then
it would be given by this quantity and
again the only intractable component was
this probability of randomization
landing in the selection region
conditional on data as a result of which
I couldn't compute the selective emily
but now with the approximation i can
just plug this approximation in and
solve for the approximate selective
emily so what i obtain with my
approximation is an approximate family
of exponential loss which is hopefully
close enough to the exact family of
randomized loss so one a good feature of
this approximation is that it is a
convex approximate selective this
selective Emilee objective that you saw
happens to be convex in nature but what
are the guarantees associated with this
point estimate well for a convex selects
region we see that the Selective Emily
actually happens to be a globally
consistent estimator and in particular
it happens to be consistent for
non-local sequences of parameter now I
don't want to go into the mathematical
details of it but just want to point out
that non-local sequences of parameter is
basically a regime of inference where
it's very hard to obtain select
consistent estimators so for instance
the knife point estimate is certainly
inconsistent if you look at the OLS
estimator that just happens to be
inconsistent very trivially but if you
did not use randomization and you use
the Selective so the little is also
conditional law so if you try to
maximize that law and obtain the MLE
then the Emily there would be
inconsistent in these regime of
inference yes no it's not it's just a
regime of inference so you look at CLT
for local sequences of parameter right
CLT you look at an order 1 over root and
neighborhood of mu you look at local
neighborhoods but non local
neighborhoods are things like same so if
root mu and were bounded so this would
be this this is when I'm looking at a 1
by root n neighborhood of the actual
parameter so this is called local
sequences of parameter but non-local is
say I fix mu n to be mu same U is minus
1 then root and mu n basically goes to
minus infinity as n tends to infinity so
this is a non-local sequence of
parameter if I fix mu n to be mu which
is just minus 1 that's a non-local
sequence of parameter where root n mu is
converging to minus infinity as n tends
to infinity so that's a regime of
inference where your selection events
are becoming rarer and rarer and rarer
and it's it's becoming harder to provide
inference so even in those hard regimes
I'm claiming that the selectively Emily
based on this randomized law happens to
be a consistent
estimator
you see general look if I just trying to
understand what the second X is telling
telling you what you're asserting with
the second line reasoning so I'm saying
if I just use the Li at all conditional
law which didn't have any form of
randomization in it you were
conditioning on the selection event
based on the data and if you compute it
you could also maximize that law and try
and compute the selectively Emily from
that law all I'm saying is that that
selectively Emily doesn't have desirable
consistency properties it's not a
consistent estimator
so surgery ended in the rate of
consistency how does the randomization
proper talk up in in there so in the
rate of okay so why to give you an
intrusive intuitive sense why the
randomized largest eels a globally
consistent selectively Emily where the
where is the non randomized Lord doesn't
an easy way to see if the non randomized
law is not a smooth law as you can see
it's just truncated like you you have
this Gaussian law truncated to the
selection event it's just it is putting
mass zero outside the selection region
and that truncation is just like a zero
one truncation like you have mass zero
outside the selection boundary it's not
a smooth law whereas this randomize law
happens to be a smooth law so because
you are not wearing it it's it's if you
fix Tao then the rate of it's not
varying within so I don't see the rate
of consistency changing but if I make it
a parameter of n then if it is also
varying with the sample size then I'm I
should expect it should affect the rate
of like the rate of consistency should
depend on tau if it's a function of the
sample size just again before we get too
far away just to understand that second
assertion the little red X you see
there's some you know natural set which
if you condition on you know you you run
low so you take the nonzero selection
nonzero coordinates where they go and
now all I'm saying is that if that
selection was having it heard yes not
get a consistent Emily if you were to
compute the Emily of that law so that's
also a law it also it is again another
exponential family of laws but the thing
is that the reference measure there is
not smooth so it's not a smooth family
of laws that's the reason why the Emily
happens to be very unstable in those
cases and it doesn't have desirable
consistency properties you can you can
basically construct a counter example to
show that it is inconsistent the thing
that is making the randomized law win
over the non-randomized law here is just
the smoothness but the smoothness is
contributing to a consistent selectively
Emily if you yeah if you if tau is
converging to zero that's a pathological
case yes but but we don't even I'm not
very sure if intuitively it makes sense
if tau goes to zero probably you expect
these randomize laws to converge to the
non randomized look but I think the
mathematical proof of this still needs
some part where you have viewed
conditions coming up and they're not
very easy to verify so I'm not very
confident about making statements and
those regimes yeah
so it's basically consistent at a rate
or which is slightly less than half so
any rate that you take which is slightly
less than half it's consistent but this
consistency of this selectively Emily I
realize just a month ago has some very
nice properties Conda associated with
Bayesian post selective inference it
actually is very closely related to
posterior consistency it's something
that I should have realized much earlier
but I really like the selective Emily
also because if you were to now do
inference in a Bayesian model instead of
a frequentist model it has it gives you
desirable frequentist guarantees in the
sense that the Bayesian randomized post
selective law that you construct happens
to be consistent because the selectively
Emily starts concentrating around the
right parameter so maybe I'll skip over
the section where I thought I would
describe the selection that goes on in
the QTL example where I basically
applied this approximation I can just
give you the gist so like I already told
you in the first stage you marginally
screen the e jeans where you compute
marginal correlations of each gene with
the set of local variants around it you
compute P values based on these marginal
Association and you are testing a global
know that this gene has no association
with any of the variants around it so
you can conduct same you can construct a
bonferroni or Symes global p-value and
once you have a p-value for each of the
genes what you do is pass the p-values
through a BH C and that's how they try
to control FDR at the level of agents so
this is basically describing the
selection and once you have the new
genes you run a lasso for each of the
Egan's
to report a variance I'm skipping over
them a bit and this is basically to give
you a snapshot of how the inference
compares so we saw that naive inference
was bad this is just Li for which is
adjusting for lasso which is just one
stage of the mining because you have
mined the e genes and that's not lasso
so that's why you see that Lila so
really falls short of coverage because
it's not accounting for all of the
selection here
where is this approximation method that
I implemented is adjusting for this
hierarchical mining both the screening
of a genes and a variance so it's giving
valid coverage guarantees you're saying
it gives valid coverage guarantees but
yes there is a bit of computational
instability here that the coverage is
around 83% so the target is 90% whereas
all these are like more or less good
it's slightly less here it's around 83%
because of some computational
instability I forget what it is exactly
but so we never tried the sampling
approach here because still this was a
very high dimensional problem and the
sampler isn't that developed to deal
with really high dimensional problems so
so we didn't try it here I rather tried
my approximation method here so I don't
know the sampler is currently still not
in a stage where you can apply it for
really high dimensional problems yes so
there are actually that's a harder
that's a harder selection but I can
still describe that selection yes
it's an optimization objective again I
did not talk about what optimization
objective but okay so let me go over
that slide and just come over to the
point that whatever I'm doing here is
actually very general in the sense that
it's not committed to just Allah so you
can like replace it with any loss you
have and any sort of penalty any sort of
convex penalty typically because that
gives you convex election regions and
you can interpret those selection
regions geometrically much better
so the beard selection can be cast as an
optimization objective again like the
whole marginal screening together with
the BH it can be cast as an optimization
objective with a convex loss and a
convex penalty so the ratio of my noise
scale to the estimated noise in the data
was one over two I just went with it
like I don't have a principled way of
cruising it I just fixed it at one over
two and I I computed the non-randomized
analogue like I did all the process
without adding any noise and I saw that
the selections were very comparable so I
did not look for any other tau any like
I I just went with that choice so it's
not it's still a very dark way of
choosing tau we should have more
principled ways of choosing tau may be
something like he suggested that we
should look at maybe some optimization
objective that tells us the trade-off
between selection and inference how much
you losing power for this no you tell
so there there are parts associated at
both stages so what do you mean like we
do gain in inferential part but we lose
selection power right because we're
doing slightly noisy version of
selection so surprisingly like like I
said I just fixed it to be 1 over 2 and
I check the selections I compare the
selections with the non randomized
analogues without using any selection
and both at the stage of screening
agents and a variance we were doing
better than I mean we were weren't doing
very different from them to be precise
at the stage of agents we we select even
more agents than they do and that's
because this BH happens to be more like
it just tends to be less conservative
when you add a little bit of noise and
it was actually suiting us more even in
the agent stage it was making BH behave
be a little less conservative but at the
events stage we were over selecting a
bit more we were over selecting a few
more noise variables but we were
actually capturing as much signal as
they were as far as simulations go I
don't know what what it is in reality
but that was the outcome of simulations
so as expected again the length of
intervals of the approximate method
happens to be pretty much better than
the lead early at all intervals 1.5
times shorter than they are and as
expected both these intervals are longer
than the unadjusted or naive intervals
because you pay a price for selection
and this is a comparison of the risks of
the selective Emily with the knife
estimates and here again the point
estimator is performing reasonably well
in terms of risk as well so let me I
don't know if I have time for this
should I go on for a few more minutes or
three minutes are you
you feel really good I mean I'm good for
ten minutes maybe I can try and wrap up
in ten more minutes that's good
so I told you a bit
so I told you so far about frequency
selection or selection in a frequentist
model post all the selection we
described a Gaussian model on the data
but what if you were a Bayesian and you
maybe had a prior on the parameters of
interest that I discovered from
selection how can I incorporate
inference in in a Bayesian framework and
give you Bayesian credible intervals and
maybe a Bayesian estimator so this is
again I just want to go through this
concrete example without going
philosophically into why we might have a
Bayesian model it's as simple as that
say you have a prior and you tell me
like I have prior information on the
parameters you discovered how can I
incorporate that prior information in my
model let's look at a concrete example
so n is 200 Peas thousand I have a
patient data generative process so I
generate my parameters beta from this
mixture model where it's a mixture of
two laplace distributions with
probability 90 I draw each coordinate of
beta from this Laplace distribution
which is very concentrated around zero
and with probability 10% I draw it from
another Laplace distribution which is
not so concentrated around zero so I'm
actually drawing a sparse vector beta
which is determined by this two prior
now once I draw my beta conditional on
beta and XS I draw my y is again and
here plus some I'm adding some Gaussian
noise to the Y so it's X beta plus some
Gaussian noise so what is my baseline
method my baseline method I run lasso I
discovered E and I forget about
selection I just go about doing the
usual Bayesian procedure I append a
prior on my beta e that is the
parameterization that I discovered from
lasso to this usual Gaussian model which
I assume like okay so selection did
suggest to me that e is a sufficiently
interesting selection event
let me parameterize my model on
by Exhibit A so this is my canonical
method or my usual Bayesian posterior
that I would work with yes so the when
you say on it just is it just there is
no I'm not I'm just looking at the
untranslated likelihood so so far I've
been looking at the truncated likelihood
which was like looking at this
likelihood truncated to selection here
I'm forgetting about selection I pretend
that there was no selection selection
did suggest to me a model and an
interesting parameterization but I
forgot about I'm not accounting for it
in any which ways it is what people
would do right now so I just told you
okay this is this is a set of
interesting parameters
maybe I didn't describe you the
experiment or maybe I did and if you did
not know anything about selection or
trusted inference what would you do you
would append a prior to the likelihood
on the data that's what you would do
unless you have another suggestion for a
more reasonable Bayesian posterior like
by definition the posterior distribution
you sort of conditioned on the outcome
of some no you're conditioned on the
data right you conditional of all of the
data I'm not I'm not trying to be
difficult there just like I don't
actually understand you maybe you're
confusing it with Bayesian variable
selection I think the question is just
sounds
maybe we understand yet this is sort of
what people would do and maybe it's hard
to think about well they could do but
like what Adams asking is look like this
is a heuristic thing to do that is not
actually like the posterior that an
actual like you know hey deal invasion
would come up with this is sort of the
best you can do with like yes that's
what I I mean if I just told you well I
had some pilot study and I ran this
experiment I ran Lhasa and there my goal
was to some discover some interesting
structure in this data and I basically
discovered that probably these are the
interesting findings now I come to you
as a statistician describe to you my
experiment and you tell me well okay
given these interesting parameters I
have a prior distribution and maybe the
likelihood I parameterize by this couch
and likelihood with mean XE batali let
me try and do Bayesian inference on it
so the unadjusted posterior what would
happen if you sort of incorrectly did
Bayesian inference basically like
failing to take into account
I guess it's yes that's what I'm do you
get back like the original prior type
mismatch for it in my head between like
what you're saying and what I think of
is like Bayesian inference
maybe you tell me what would be the
posterior maybe that you would use but I
don't know this is the true data
generative mechanism right I cannot
assume that I know the true part prior
so I put I'm just saying like I just
described you a data generative
mechanism by which I am generating my
data points but you wouldn't know it of
course it should be a black box for you
who is providing the inference I'm
saying that I use my data to discover
some interesting parameterization and at
the moment I'm interested in giving some
Bayesian inference about those
parameters of interest it's a language
like buy an adjusted posterior you mean
sort of I'm curious
principal tyrannous yes the right thing
to do yes and but still I think
statisticians even now they they would
probably think maybe I mean even if you
do like something like I don't know if
this is your this is your starting point
of inference we'll see where it can go
wrong in terms of what sort of
inferential metrics but it's not
apparently very clear I guess to people
like how can it go wrong and where can
it go wrong you're setting up a straw
man which you will like yes for us like
the Strymon does it really make sense
but maybe that doesn't matter but maybe
it does matter because you're gonna show
us something that like this yeah so
instead like again I mean I run the
randomized version of lasso so what am i
swapping here what am i comparing to I
run a noisy version of lasso and it says
suggested to me some interesting
parameterization beta II and now I look
at the posterior that I'm looking at is
this prior appended to the truncated
likelihood that I was looking at so the
truncated likelihood was precisely the
likelihood of the data then there was
this reference measure which was
randomization satisfying the selection
criterion conditional on data but this
this this is not a function of the
parameters in your models so this kind
of gets killed so what you have here
instead is the selection property which
marginalizes both over data and
randomization and it's a function of the
parameters in your model so this is a
truncated likelihood appended to the
prior well is this is this the right
thing to do and that's what I'll show
you maybe let's skip over the so like
the difference here is your conditioning
honey
the difference is that my likelihood is
different from the previous likelihood
that I used so I was a pending a prior
so in a Bayesian as a Bayesian person
you need you have a model you have a
prior model and you have a likelihood so
the likelihood there was the untreated
likelihood I did not account for
selection and the likelihood in this
case is this truncated likelihood that's
the affective difference between the two
regimes
I just don't know it in exactly Ostrom
that's the whole point if you did yes so
if you had like the exact probability in
the denominator there that would be like
Bayes rule it would be just like the
natural it would satisfy all the Bayes
rules yes but you don't want to do that
because computationally it's a problem
you don't know what I mean ideally I
would like to do that if I had the exact
probability I would just look at the
truncated likelihood appended to the
prior but the point is that again this
probability for the very same reasons
doesn't have a closed form expression so
my best bet is here let me approximate
this probability as a function of the
parameters in the model let me nail down
this probability as a function of the
parameters in the model and it's a very
same approximation that was that I was
using in the frequentist sense also
except that now this probability region
is slightly different because it's
marginalizing over the data as well I
guess I'm trying to understand the
distinction between things you're doing
for computational reasons which are find
reasons to do things like it's wrong I
don't have so so this is the truncated
right likelihood right without the Hat
without the approximation this would
just be like
the exact conditional distribution the
denominator is part so I plug in an
approximation good thank you cuz it but
then you said like and we don't know it
or something like that but that I'm
getting trying to get it the distinction
between like hard to compute and like
fundamentally unknowable because there's
stuff missing yeah it's hard to compute
the exact probability is hard to compute
yes no problem so I'm trying to wrap up
so basically here the computational cost
in Bayesian inference would be
essentially involved in computing this
probability again and it's similar in
spirit to the approximation that I
talked about in a frequentist sense just
the difference was in frequentist
inference I was approximating the
reference measure but sure I this
reference measure doesn't contribute to
the posterior because it's not a
function of the parameters in the model
rather what contributes to the posterior
is this normalizer to the truncated
likelihood so if you believe me there
I'm not going into that I want to show
this one slide and maybe a slide after
this so let's compute instead of STR
let's now compute Bayesian FCR so I
really know in simulations what my two
data generative mechanism is so I
generate my data this way and I compute
once I construct these selected
intervals based on this Bayesian
posterior selection adjusted procedure
that appended the truncated likelihood
to the prior I compute the proportion of
intervals not covering the truth amongst
the reported intervals so this is a
comparison of the Bayesian FCR that I
have my target is 90% these are the
selective intervals these are the
intervals that I obtain when I do not
factor in selection at all and you can
see how bad they are these are the
little intervals which are frequent
intervals they are not Bayesian in that
sense and this is splitting splitting
again you know overcome selection bias
so you don't face the problems with
splitting at all these are the posterior
means that I compute based on the
different term distributions and these
are the length of the intervals so again
the selection adjusted
posterior that we obtain by appending
the truncated likelihood to the prior
happens to win on a number of
inferential metrics and what I wanted to
say again connect this Bayesian business
to the point estimator that I talked
about that was the selectively Emily so
in some ways the consistency the global
consistency of the selectively Emily
with our randomized procedures also
leads to posterior consistency in the
sense that we have merging of posterior
inferences of two patients who may start
out with different prior specifications
so that's a very desirable property to
have and it's very much connected to the
fact it just follows from the fact that
the selective Emily starts concentrating
around the right parameter but I won't
take more time of yours or numb in
trying to talk about this anymore so to
wrap up what we have right now is a very
general procedure like James already
realized that in the screening of a
genes we were doing much beyond law so
we had marginal Association test plus we
had this another big beast of BH
procedure but essentially as long as we
can cast our query as this optimization
problem with some convex loss and convex
penalty it's pretty easy to put this
whole machinery into force you just
randomize it using this linear
perturbation term and it allows us to
look beyond lots of which i think is a
is a great consequence of this
approximation paradigm the second thing
is which I brushed under the carpet I
never talked about it
inference is really an arduous task in
the sense that you always have to make
those uncomfortable decisions about a
model and a reasonable target to look at
so unlike your exploratory analysis
where you know maybe you just have to
find some interesting effects inference
comes with some difficult choices and
whatever I describe to you in some sense
is very model agnostic I can work with
different models yet have the same
guarantees that I was talking about and
have valid confidence intervals so
nothing is dyed input
tickler to the saturated or the full
model that I presented to you throughout
my talk I went with it for consistency's
sake and that was what Lea Dahl was
using but it's not tied to that
particular model if you have a better
model in mind which is a function of
selection could be guided by selection
not guided by selection at all I could
still provide you inference with all
these guarantees what's really blocking
us okay okay so I just wanted to say the
randomized inference was still I believe
a little hard to deal with but that's
the road ahead of us and with that I'm
going to wrap up thank you
[Applause]